non-minimalists
and i think one of the keys what we're
going to be talking about today is the
excess
stuff in our lives so let's talk about
what excess means at first because
my excess might be different from your
excess right ryan so
so for me the my my self-imposed
definition of excess here is
excess is that which does not add value
to our
lives and so when we talk about what
adds value does it serve a purpose
so if i have a pen that serves a purpose
it's adding value to my life
or does it bring me joy yeah we were at
your house yesterday
uh recording some living room
conversations for youtube
and uh you have some artwork on the wall
it may not have a particular function
necessarily but it does it does serve a
different purpose
right where it brings you joy that
aesthetic pleasure and so in a way you
could even argue that
it does have a function it does serve a
purpose it it enhances the aesthetics or
the beauty of your home yeah
absolutely and so that's what excess is
in the the terms of today and i found
this video someone actually it was our
friend mike atkins sent it over to me
very
strangely and it i didn't know at the
time we were going to be doing an
episode about excess but it is the
perfect
video to describe well this human
condition
of i think we're drawn to excess in a
way so let's take a look at
let's check it out
whether you drive a forks wagon or you
drive
a bentley the road remains the same
doesn't it
[Music]
whether you speak on a samsung or you
speak on an iphone
x whoever you're scaling remains the
same isn't it
[Music]
whether you're flying economy
or you're flying business the
destination where you're heading remains
the same isn't it
whether you're wearing a simple fast
track
or you wear an omega or a raw legs the
time remains the same isn't it
it's quite amazing how we work ourselves
up so much
with increasing the standard of living
that we forget to increase the standard
of our life
and which is why wherever i travel i
make an appeal to people there's nothing
wrong with an omega
there's nothing wrong with bentley god
bless you with that and if you have it
drive it no problem
but it's trying to enhance and increase
and improvise the standard of your
living
please please do not compromise
with the standard of your life it's not
the standard of your living that makes
you happy
it's the standard of your life that
makes you happy
and very often we forget
to give attention to those things that
can truly
make us happy
which is why i i i always say
things that i'm talking about they have
utility value right
not happiness value travel business
class of first class
travel no problem driver bentley no
problem
but in doing so never ever
compromise on those principles
that also improve the standard of
your life and therefore
i always say some people are so poor
so poor so absolutely
poor that all they have is money
that's all they have that's all that
i consider that life a power district in
life
if all you have is money you're the
poorest person in the world
because there's more to life than money
and there's way more to life than what
money can buy
and therefore many times say if you want
to truly know how rich you are
drop a tear and see how many hands come
forth
to wipe that tear ladies and gentlemen
a happiness a happiness
and our increased standard of life is
not in things it's in people
it's relationships it's meaningful
heartfelt deep bondings of love
that bring fulfillment to the heart is
those meaningful
exchanges of love that we share with
each other in relationships
that brings true joy to the heart and
isn't it the
greatest irony it's something that
brings in the greatest fulfillment we
very conveniently neglect
in just running after increasing and
enhancing our standard of living
wow man have you it's good have you seen
that one before i haven't and i i hadn't
either
and um yeah the a few things that stood
out to me where he
he sort of differentiated with some word
play there the standard of living versus
the standard of life
yeah if i were to append that a little
bit i would just say the the
don't don't sacrifice your standards for
a standard of living
you and i often talk about raising your
standards
but but uh lowering the expectations and
right now we have so many expectations
we have these
excess expectations or better yet we
have these
expectations of excess if i win the
lottery i can get that yacht
i can buy the mansion and just before
this you revealed to me that if you won
the lottery accidentally
i don't know how you would but maybe you
walked by the winning ticket you picked
it up
and all of a sudden you realize like i
am 1.6
billion dollars richer your life would
not change appreciably from how it
changes right now
you might have a a slightly newer car
you might have a um might have own a
house
yeah own a house instead of renting one
being able to own a house outright
but not a considerably different
dwelling from what you live in now in
terms of square feet
or or or opulence you're probably not
going to go buy a mansion in beverly
hills with that money
but as he said in that that video
there's nothing inherently wrong with
the house or the car
or whatever it's when we put those
things
first when we think that that excess is
what allows
us to succeed yeah and and in our
society in our culture the trinkets of
success
are are the things that we use to
measure our lives but
they're not a measurement of fulfillment
or joy or happiness
they're a measure measurement of
material wealth
yeah i think he put a grade i mean he
what was his name
oh it doesn't matter it doesn't matte
doesn't matter
it's okay if you don't know his name but
but you know what he did
is he did a great job of explaining how
hey look
yeah it's okay to have the bentley drive
the bentley it's okay to it's okay to
wear rolex if that's what you want to
wear it's okay to fly first class
the problem is when we forsake our did
he say our principles
yeah he did say principles yeah and what
he called the
the standard of life is really what he
was talking about is having your
principles
what uh you and i would refer to them as
as values now we would delineate
different types of values
we could talk about those today when
we're answering some of these questions
and the thing that really stood out to
me is he said that
that some people are so poor is that all
they have is money
yeah and then if you have all you have
is money then you're the poorest
person in the world yeah and man that
that stuck with me because we can't have
excess we get to these points where we
we um we amassed the excess the average
american house has 300 000 items in it
it didn't happen overnight you didn't go
out and buy 300 000 things at home depot
and walmart this weekend
it happened over years decades several
decades sometimes
so you get to that point where you're
like my mom when she passed she was 65
years old and she had 65 years worth of
accumulations
in a tiny one-bedroom apartment
and she wasn't a hoarder she just held
onto things she had
excess she had 14 winter coats in her
closet and she lived in florida she had
these things
that she wasn't using didn't make her a
bad person it didn't even make her
wrong it just meant that
that um like most of us and i think this
is the human
[Music]
we condition we don't when we don't stop
ourselves we don't stop back
we always want the new thing and it
drives forward innovation
it's the reason we have all these really
we have these cool microphones and we
have
like we we have this the these sound
panels we i have a
iphone in my pocket and it's because
like we crave
innovation and we go for more and more
and more and more
that becomes a problem when it's
unchecked when
we don't start thinking about why do i
need this this new
thing yeah i know you have an older
version of the iphone
right yeah it's a few versions old yeah
and
and there and for you right now there
isn't a good reason for you to
upgrade to a new one now for me in my
current situation i upgraded
last year um uh whenever the
the the 10 count so the the version
before the one that's the
the three newest ones now the access
whatever
the first version of the 10. yeah the 10
one x1
1x i'm so confused right now yeah i
don't know but uh
um for me there there are a couple
things on there
that have really aided my relationships
personally
um when i say relationships my
relationship with my partner backs which
i could be fine with
an old flip phone with her but with ella
like i was on facetime with her last
night and it has the
animoji feature and yeah she was having
a meltdown before i called her and you
know she's in a different city right now
and and when i called her i
was able to put the dragon and emoji on
and so i was a dragon
as i talked to her oh wow and uh it was
it was extremely valuable like to have
her laughing by the end of the
conversation because she was having a
bad day
yesterday and so sometimes these things
can aid
our life and so you and i aren't going
to say hey get rid of all of your things
everything is excess
the question is does it actually bring
any sort of value to your life yeah